for years we've tried our best to crack
down on anything that's wrong on our
site sometimes it does get into the
criminal in which case we're good at
helping out victims and cops on this and
they do learn that we're we're good at
that we need to get better so recently
we saw the assistance of law enforcement
and groups like the National Center for
Missing and Exploited Children we've
gotten better at it we continue to talk
to them to listen to them because more
will be needed in the future we do
respond to requests from law enforcement
we act consistent with due process and
constitutional values we've operated as
if the Constitution and rule of law was
in effect over the last eight years and
we do look forward to President Obama
reinstating constitutional law